[Music]
and 3 2 1 action
hi hi hi hi
yeah yeah yeah yeah what are we talking
about today well today we have Josh hi
honey
showing up on JK news who asked for it
for literally as long as I've been
working for this [ __ ] channel finally
did it we put him on camera yeah there
you go
[Music]
so Josh I guess you do a low you've done
a fair amount of things for JK over the
years yes what do you do what are you
doing now or what are you chasing or
going after this is what I get people
mad every week what is your job I just I
just get people really really mad but in
a funny way funny I mean josh is MVP of
JK party yeah for reals there's a lot of
times won't be behind the camera be
laughing because it's like you can't
write [ __ ] like this like got it like
you literally I couldn't even in my like
if I had ideal circumstances I was in a
super motivated writing but I couldn't
write some of the [ __ ] it's just so out
there all the time it's like what the
[ __ ] was that one that you said like
it's a way to say some say in says wins
notice I'm saying win says others say
hey that's branding endless
entertainment listen it is that is true
that's true so I mean like what do you
what do you have to now because I know
that you're like sometimes you're on
Jake you party if you got the time some
oh I'm really curious too because you
just disappear something I do sometimes
you go radio sometimes hey Josh you
wanna come to air talk oh no I have to
have but what about lunch you got for
lunch you
[ __ ] Facebook message never anything
from you never know you want to get
lunch today
okay today there's no I mean the only
time we're ever going to eat together is
when we're at Jake I will get a bunch of
together what do you want to go to what
do you want it's playing out right now
no let's go here
let's go see boy so boy we went to soil
ask don't exactly what day yeah in time
oh yeah and we're December 11 31 what
what Oh jakey party Joe yeah they put
you to help how is it
take a party Josh is saying is he never
wants to hang out with you [ __ ] always
we got I believe I have [ __ ] proof
and [ __ ] you know I said the call
[ __ ] out you gotta be here at 9:00 this
will always text me
a little bit late I'm so sorry if you're
meeting some Far Far East where I'm from
I still come on hey hey hey hey don't
touch me haha about this beautiful
relationship that we have this week it's
funny though because you guys watch Jack
a party and you see Julia Josh Fite all
the time and it's funny because they do
that off camera too but it's in a very I
don't know if you guys have friendships
like that but that's a pretty it's a
pretty normal thing like they don't
actually hate each other good this is
the first this is like the first kind of
friendship that I have I know
thud I just cost me just one of the
strings so I just wanna like see we can
all get along yeah you guys are weird
I don't think we can actually say hey
don't be John well I mean I've been up
to a couple of projects some I can't say
in the AC but nothing too big nothing
too big big enough to sign it well
you know that you randomly pop up a no
for the hora panini music video I was
like it's like what do you mean you're
the head like it was pretty quality shot
that shot in downtown was it just all
green screen or like we're talking about
Lola sexes panini music video you're in
the actual music video come back I want
how did this happen first of all yeah
who hit you up my friend hit me up I'm
not sure if I can say isn't you okay my
friend gave me a mic diva the one who
directed it no okay no yeah yeah was he
doing visual effects on it or no we're
just like you just said hey okay sure
you pop up and then you see like a
little mouse and like oh [ __ ] did you to
meet him I was just like in his area I'd
never wants like toxic yeah want to be
like hey I just wanted okay put that guy
in the back you never actually want to
go up and just say hey I'm a big family
especially they're not working yeah you
want to be profession you know that's
really bad let's say for instance like
there's like a good chance like you guys
will meet again you don't want to be
like oh he was that guy that just came
up and said oh yeah yeah fun fact for
any of you that work on like or anything
really to do with people like high
profile or any like any any kind of
celebrity or something that were people
know who they are don't don't fan nerd
out at them if you're working that's
really unprofessional like how your
thing is like oh yeah just guess I've
run into them again it's like what are
these chances super high you should be
hanging out a little dolls X all the
diamonds
next time we just to hang out at the bar
together it's like a 50/50 chances no
shittier bets in Vegas all right he does
more often then we are getting lunch one
day just because I feel like I I never
want to say anything's not impossible
because a lot of things that I think oh
that could never happen like I will
never get here and just lo and behold
the next actually you know Josh's secret
is to always think nothing is not
possible I think like oh it's not saying
like nothing's impossible you think
nothing is not possible very Josh see ya
until I got another spreadsheet all
right 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so it is possible
the math checks out yeah yeah that's
cool nice to say even starting in music
videos you do an NDA approach there
anything you can talk about is there
anything that you want people to know
which I'm doing it on I'm doing twitch
making vlogs editing for a couple of
people doing social media Merc you never
tell us who who though oh you want NDA
for them no no I'm on India it's a
couple it's a couple okay people or a
couple trying to become YouTube people
cool yeah
nice so see they have the ropes
no cousin how they all know about like
JK so I think that's really fun oh
that's even better
yeah so that's even better so they don't
know anything about my about my past
usually when people ask me if I do like
video stuff and then I go for who I
avoid same Jake they try to get like oh
can I do a Brando with them or you want
free you want free food is what
I've had that happen so as I've had that
happen so much yeah I think at the
beginning it's like it's like kind of
like a negative feeling it's like
sometimes positive but sometimes
negative because you just want like a
generic or you want enough vintage
relationship but I think what you're
trying to get at is you want you want
them to appreciate you for your work
yeah I think it depends on like I guess
who I'm talking to if I'm talking to
like a young asian person venture but if
I talk to like like just like a general
like middle-aged white guy I'll be like
blah blah we're gonna take your films I
work for a comedy YouTube channel like I
do I work I often say YouTube and people
now a lot of people think I just work
for the company I work in YouTube and
they're just like oh can you figure out
how to do this I'm like no that's not
what I meant
what YouTube I work I was trying to
explain like okay so then within YouTube
the people that put videos on YouTube do
not necessary to know like what I'm like
okay I think like old world and new
worlds of suits together no sometimes
it's even like relatively young people
like people our age and stuff like that
I'm just do you do not know how this
works
do you not understand how these things
work like you you know what YouTube is
right like you know what you know how
you know I feel like I remember I've
mentioned this to Marian's family my
girlfriend multiple times and they
they're still really confused about it
we're like I feel like I feel like my
memory may be a little bit fuzzy but I
think a few times they've like brought
up YouTube problems with me like to pass
on to the heads of YouTube and I'm like
even if I did work there it doesn't work
that way
I would be like here and then Susan
Wojcicki is like
very tough and then I don't even know
she could do anything work for YouTube
you just call her up and do all your
parents know that like you work at
YouTube yeah how do they take it like
when you said hey I work for well it was
like it was kind of like Nelson's thing
or they would just always ask me like
wait so how did they meet Winnie again
yeah they get X amount of views then
they get paid $11 and yeah then we all
get played out yeah that's the most when
I'm explaining my job to people is like
why does that make money you know it's
really confident it's a fair question to
be honest because it's like optics brand
explain like brand deals and
sponsorships and then our revenue and
then the user apply we don't
that's why we have patreon yeah oh yeah
by the way I subscribe to our patreon
because it's because of that we can make
videos like this and support all of us
to continue to do this without starving
because it is it just might despite what
a lot of like really really successful
youtubers look like it is quite a grind
to get to that size despite what really
successful youtubers look like we're not
one of them are not unfortunately on the
level of people that are buying Ferraris
and Lamborghinis and stuff unfortunately
at least I'm not I I would love to get
to that point in one day my car doesn't
even have power windows that's a roll it
up like I chose it because it's cheap I
was gonna say it's like but Nelson did
kind of choose that but I feel like a
part of Nelson also chose neck because
he was like yeah I think it's shorter
love like a thousand bucks just roll up
my windows you know how could save
another thousands you know power locks
Jeep everybody that [ __ ] everybody
everybody everybody give it up for
Nelson who bought a stick you think this
car is inefficient now just wait till I
have to work for it
you didn't get like windows or anything
you've been getting locks on the doors
sure my windows are plastic has windows
yes there's the locks on your door you
guys is why it's gonna get broken into
think people are like oh why don't you
lock your doors I'm like because you can
unzip my windows from the outside the
zipper the zippers are not on the inside
of the car like you can just pull out
the velcro unzip and you're like hey I'm
inside of a car now a lot of times
people will just are like people that
are trying to break in will like cut the
soft tops and stuff which really sucks
don't do that why just unzip the window
yeah people do that though so that's the
reason why oh you know if you want to
get to my car unzip it please don't cut
my windows are convinced Hill's gonna
get a hardtop got a patreon maybe I can
make some money on it in the notes we
like protect me from the winters dijanna
oh yeah so you said you're editing and
doing your own vlogs I know that a lot
of people want you to put out some what
day well by the time this comes out what
is tomorrow try to give you a plug in
say thirteen thirteen fourteen the 14th
November 14 so you're pointing that
specific day ha Josh why the 14th why
not any other day because that has to be
why it just has to be the 14 does your
dear nd is expired that day
I just want to come out as soon as
possible you guys want blonde now I know
today because after this I have to do
during this all over right now okay I
mean it'll take you about two days to
upload on this internet so what happens
if the video isn't out by the time one
challenge one hot the one chicken I mean
I feel like the one the Hot Chip
challenge will eventually give you the
hot [ __ ] everybody should do a follow-up
video that does the hot chef challenge
and then immediately do a challenge it's
about ten minutes away from when I ate
the hot chick and it's gonna be a ride I
know this is probably like really
self-explanatory in the title itself but
it's basically a chip that's like
SuperDuper hot yeah it's like that Ghost
Pepper season delight chip yeah it's
like a Dorito that they just like no no
why would why would you ever put
yourself do that pain that's not worth
it George is a freak of nature because
we were eating it's still funny bit for
JK party yeah I mean he just keeps
saying it's dancing on my tongue yeah I
used to be able to explain I can't do
you can't do spice anyway when did you
realize you couldn't do spice anymore
whether during party so I think maybe
that was his peak during party is my
peak cuz I was hanging out with my
friends the other day I think they GE
the gave me some of the you know from
the what's the name of that one channel
where they just like ones hot one meal a
step yeah they gave me like the last
time a couple of the others and I was
just I was not really too good really at
this point in my life sorry right this
one my live like my mouth can handle
more spicy foods than my [ __ ] share
great I'm suffering afterwards every
single time just like yo this is
I still feel more covered I might need a
bust out that [ __ ] milk but anyway
subscribe to Josh's channels well then
yeah because he's gonna be busting out a
[ __ ] a video tomorrow apparent video
yeah on the 14th by the time that you
see this sin it's not up because they're
so I'll get like a little nugget of
comedy
[Music]
take a trip to the future follow them on
Twitter Instagram and twitch what it
what is it I've been told to make a
tick-tock that's why I keep em emulsify
at the same time you do really well on
tick tock like you didn't think so but
yeah but I feel like tick tock this is
kind of like out of my own
mmm cuz they comment in the comment
section below if you think Josh would do
well in tick tock review should stick to
all these other platforms
hey nothing is not I say I won't do I
end up doing whenever I say I will do I
end up not so I was like a complete like
so I will not subscribe to josh channel
usually I won't not subscribe to our
Channel yeah yeah Eddie's twitch follow
on Twitch - yeah follow me on Twitch dub
halo I play a lot of games I do drawing
streams I chat with people I might also
be doing a travel vlog I mean the
traveling oh well travel to a travel -
it's a travel store well are you gonna
buy a streamer backpack i my friends is
that they might let me borrow one when
I'm away dude I feel like tick tock is
so your brand cuz tick tock is about
embracing cringe and trend at the same
time together never felt so insulted in
my life
[Music]